good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
thursday is so close to friday
yeah yeah so exciting that it's thursday
so blessed to be here
on a thursday let's take a minute to
appreciate
the fact that it's not monday it's not
tuesday
you thought maybe it was no it's not
wednesday oh no
it's thursday and that's a great place
to be in the week it's a great place
it's not too far you're not like sunday
like you're so far gone like there's so
much hope on the horizon so
everyone just close your eyes appreciate
this moment like we have so much
excitement ahead of us
soak it in this is now meditation
podcast yes
um yes
yeah i don't know if that's relaxing yes
it's asmr i'm obsessed with asmr
are you is that good asmr how do you
have to hear it in order to know if it's
good yeah
yeah like i should be wearing headphones
but you guys tell me like this is what
my favorite girl josie does she does
like
i can't i can't even listen to you do
that i can't imagine that that is
peaceful please and then she like
pretends you're at the spa welcome
my name is josie i use she her pronouns
what's your name then you have like a
conversation with her got it okay
i don't think asmr is for me oh my god
it's everything of the sort
um speaking of everything of the sort
welcome to the morning toast welcome
today we have a great show for you today
it's our last show in studio for the
week we'll be podcast only tomorrow and
because it was our last visual show we
decided
to come in with me new merch ones got
minou merch
what were you gonna say my story from
last week where i was where i had a typo
in my couch
no it was like i'm using this phone case
until i get minou merged one
and i felt like miss pat moore from
downton abbey um
jeffy and i are modeling our new merch
ones spring
2020. this is for our february 17th
launch that's only this is
spring twenty twenty bucks like spring
summer
this is winter 2021 because it's
launching next week
it's february very much winter these are
very thick
cozy delicious delicious sweaters i'm
wearing the how you dern
style pop up to the side because this is
the most sickening design
and it comes with matching phone case
yes and it comes in a long-sleeve
version and it comes with a beanie too
beanie it is so [ __ ] sickening i'm so
so excited about that design
no this is like the rodeo design of our
dreams you can catch me at stagecoach
in this beanie and sweatshirt combo a
hundred percent
that's why you're wearing redheads merch
we have some really exciting merch
dropping this is the maroon
sweatshirt sickening i mean i love it
because it like looks so professional
and collegiate and smart and it's always
a good time to become a redhead but i
just feel like wearing this merch
is the actual best time to become one
it's similar to like you know
when people wear their harvard
sweatshirts 100 like
i'm a part of a book club yeah this says
i have a book club we have merch we have
interests we're interesting yeah i think
it's it's a good look for you
uh for the redheads out there i totally
agree even like non-redheads we won't
care if you wear the merch and look
smart and
don't care to participate in our book
club but also this sweatshirt is coming
in a cream color which is literally
the sweatshirt i've been dreaming of
since we launched the podcast i was like
i need a cream
logo sweatshirt i have it it's stunning
i will be wearing it all weekend
and then we're also launching mugs phone
cases
notebooks so there's so much redhead
march it's a great time to become a
redhead like all these
like and also we're it's our one year
anniversary this week of
doing redheads so for those of us who
have been on the ride since the
beginning like
this is just a little treat for us it's
a little full circle moment for the
passion projects
uh the passions are just overflowing
because now i'm obviously passionate
about redheads but i'm so passionate
about our merch now
yeah i mean i've had this phone case for
like two weeks and it has been killing
me like not to take mirror pictures
showing it off
i know and i just got my redheads phone
case and
i've also been dreaming of this phone
case because once again it's just like
sleek and cool and smart
and interesting so mark your calendars
february
17th february 17th all available at
shopmorningtoast.com
oh not to be confused like not not to be
confused with hermes.com it's
shop morning toast it's very similar i
know it's confusing because like the
designs are
kind of similar so similar anyways it's
just like so exciting
sickening march sickening the warehouse
down i'm excited for the warehouse
to get the merch out so that it won't be
so sick anymore yeah maybe we got to get
the warehouse the vaccine
we might have to we actually have like a
sickening show for you guys today i'm
really excited for everyone to hear our
interview
with jen davis from the real housewives
of dallas we actually spoke about her
last week on the show when recapping the
real housewives of dallas about how it
it feels odd her presence on the show
because she's invited to everything it's
almost like she's a castmate but it felt
like something had happened and when we
mentioned that on the show and some of
the rumors that were being spread
on blogs and read it she reached out to
us and she said she's a toaster she
loves the podcast and she'd love to just
come on and say her piece which i
thought was so cool
and she did just that we interviewed her
yesterday if you're watching on youtube
it'll be at the end of the podcast
and podcasters just keep listening she
was so um
open and honest because there was a lot
of [ __ ] that went down and she just
comes right out and says it
and i had so much respect for her so i
hope everyone listens to it with like an
open mind
and an appreciation for the transparency
because like now that she's not
of like an actual housewife she doesn't
owe us an explanation
and i just thought it was so cool of her
and i actually ended up like
loving her no me too i really liked her
approach and her outlook towards this
time in her life and what the show
meant to her i think some people might
see it differently but i think she just
had such a positive great outlook and
after speaking with her
i really hope that the stars align and
that she is a full-time housewife next
year because
i think she's so fabulous me too i think
there's i like her and there's more
there i loved her energy me too and the
fact that she's a toaster like she's
obviously a beautiful sunny and smart
queen with amazing tastes and podcast
influencers and comedians and authors
hundred percent oh man speaking of
all of this words um clubhouse
claudia and i joined clubhouse yesterday
i got i'm not i wasn't entirely sure on
what it was i'd read some articles about
it but
a girl i used to work with who haven't
literally heard from in years
she was texting me she's like i have
this invite you wanted and i was like
okay
and i just signed up and you and margo
signed up literally the same day you
you actually got the invitation i got
invitation like a week ago and i didn't
do anything i got the invitation
yesterday morning
and i signed up yesterday and then i was
like guys we should do this
and i was like thinking about i have
been thinking about it but i didn't
realize you needed an invite so like my
invite came and then i joined
yeah of course i'm not gonna go seeking
out an invite that's desperate yeah no i
hadn't gotten to that place yet but i
probably would have gotten there but i
was glad to have gotten an invite and
yesterday we spent the day sort of
trying to figure out
what's going on there you started a room
you started a room last night there was
like a lot of people on
and what i liked about it and i feel
like it has a similar kind of vibe to
how i do my instagram lives obviously
instagram live is audio and video and
clubhouse is an app where you basically
start like a chat room
just using audio and anyone can join and
you can join people you can bring people
up on the stage to moderate the
conversation with you
so first it was just me you and margo
talking about like what we thought
taylor swift's announcement was gonna be
which we're gonna get into in the past
five
and then all these people started to
join vinnie guadagnino from the jersey
shore and he really elevated
the conversation because we're huge
jersey shore fans
and it's clear that he knows what he's
doing on clubhouse and he's been on the
toast and and we were saying this on the
chat like he was actually the first
podcast i ever went on like back in the
day
he had a podcast with podcast one and i
was like so nervous because i was such a
big jersey shore fan
so he was great and then my friend marge
who's a dj and she likes um
she's like a fabulous dj like in the
city like back in normal times like if
there was a fabulous party like marge
was the dj like dolce gabbana like
everything and now she streams her
concerts on twitch and so of course
she's on clubhouse
and she texted me like because she was
like saw that i was struggling
and she was helping me and then she
joined we brought her up on the stage
and it was and she was just like being
so funny and it was just like a great
random group of people we went on for
like an hour just talking about jersey
shore
taylor swift clubhouse and it was
awesome like i actually really enjoyed
it i enjoyed it i learned a lot about
clubhouse like i'm feeling
better and i feel like for the toaster
community like it could be a really
great place for all of us audio like
that's literally what we do
that is what we do so i think there are
going to be ways that we can find to
make it super fun and toasty
i'm feeling like i kind of want to treat
it just like my instagram lives like
you know some people say they're a hit
and i think like
the element of just like anyone can
stumble in and that's what marge was
telling me she's like
it's crazy especially at night like
people start rooms about random
conversations and then like bethany
frank will drop in like
celebrities are just dropping into
people's rooms to like hear interesting
conversations
yeah it's like this everyone not a lot
of nobody has like millions of followers
yet so it's kind of like an even playing
field
yeah and it's nice that it's audio so
you don't have to worry about you know
getting your
look together to get on a room so you're
just jumping from room to room yeah and
so that is
like a benefit but then another thing
that i i felt last night was like
i was literally laying in bed like a
piece of [ __ ] like legs spread like a
finger on my nose like
but also my phone was laying on my chest
and i was just talking and it was so
comfortable
and while that's great because you know
i hate putting on makeup that also seems
like a recipe for disaster because you
feel like you're just talking with your
sisters and friends and there are things
you say
publicly and there are things you say
privately and you know sometimes some of
the things i say are a little mean but i
would always say it to you
yeah and so just having clubhouse like
make me feel so comfortable like
actually scared me a little bit but i
think that's what makes the
conversations
actually interesting and because the
audio like doesn't live on i think they
want you to be comfortable
yeah that's true like the you watch it
live and then i think it disappears like
there's no
archive which thank god yeah because
we're i'm the queen of you know
so my handle is at jackie oscar and you
can follow me for some really lively
discussions do you know what my handle
is
a girl with no job it is but when i
first signed up someone took girl with
no job so i did girl with no job
and i went to go see who find found it
and it was a guy named rotem tamir and
i'm like okay israeli like i can relate
maybe this person follows me
so i dm at rotem tamir on instagram and
i'm like
and i saw he's responding to my stories
like come to israel or
i love l.a like just responding to stuff
so i'm like are you the road temp to
mirror who stole my username and he was
like yes i finally got your attention
and i was like he was like he gave it
back to me like no problem he was so
nice and shout out rotem tamir for not
making me like pay five thousand dollars
wow that is so crazy i didn't know you
had that experience yesterday and that
it was like so successful well you don't
watch my stories like i chronicled the
whole thing oh did you
sometimes i don't watch the sound i'm
not gonna lie especially when it's like
you're talking to the camera and oh so
like just my pride and joy
that's crazy i literally watch
everything i mean i guess like you put
out like ten percent of the stories that
i put out
i make my story so that you don't have
to listen to sound and i respond to you
because that's how i listen
all of your stories i'm like lol like i
respond to all of yours too so i can't
believe you don't watch my face talking
ones those are my favorite ones
some of them i do but also like
sometimes you're recapping a show and
it's like either we recap it on the
toast
or i don't watch the show so i just tap
tap tap
that's tapping tap tapped tap three
[ __ ] chaps
wow she puts on her edges and she
finally says you know what
i'm like now that i'm thinking about why
i don't watch certain things
i'm realizing that if you're talking to
the camera i like when there's a little
bit of text underneath just like letting
you know what you're talking about i
think that would be like
really great i know i'm just like so
lazy yeah and they're really [ __ ] like
if you caption like oh my god username
drama
with my clubhouse like i would have been
like what yeah no you're right about
that people are
getting really good at that i also do
wish there was some sort of closed
captioning
feature i think there is oh i think
there is i've seen on other people they
should be
me they're text just like coming across
the screen of what they're saying
i will do better on you know
categorizing and
teasing teasing yeah you're right i just
throw [ __ ] at the wall and i'm like
hopefully someone thinks that's funny
yeah like if you just gave like a couple
words about what this story is about
like i think
it would be even more engaging that's a
decent idea great yeah
love to see it i'll work on it that and
my clubhouse persona
yes very very excited i definitely felt
like a radio host like you know khloe
kardashian when she moved to miami and
she was on that show
what up miami i definitely felt like a
grandma trying to use the microwave like
getting onto a new platform is
just it's crazy out there yeah like when
i got on tick tock i felt
old because like all the kids who were
making like sickening edited videos were
so young
with clubhouse everybody i feel dumb yes
that's what i was going to say everyone
wants a genius
everyone who i know on it is like a top
leader in their field
yes so i'm like oh i'm dumb i can't
figure this out yeah no like
everyone is elon musk everyone has
bitcoin
ever it's a big bitcoin community i know
and so i do
feel like you know that's what we need
to do i feel like the intern
yeah no i definitely feel like the new
kid uh-huh
in school which is the worst yeah it has
like a linkedin
feel and just given our work like we're
not big linkedin people
i actually deleted my linkedin a few
years ago and so
it's it's it's a new vibe for us
but i'm i'm here for it to be like in
the professional community
yeah so follow us jackie ashrae and girl
with no job
no i got the one b girl no job but
sweet um anything else you want to talk
about before we dive in
no not much just you know bruce has just
been
such a sweet sweet love
and he's really been taking up my days
so if i'm going to recap my day
yesterday it's just
bruce it's bruce bruce lunch breakfast
first
dinner dinner yeah bruce clubhouse yes
bruce bruce bruce knowles yes uh you saw
magnolia last night
but i'll one up yeah i saw michaela i
know there was a battle of the sister
center if you were on our clubhouse room
you knew that that's what was going down
snitch came over for dinner i cooked a
romantic dinner for two
while nols and bruce got it on this like
bruno was literally like
like just is bruno's not neutered no
he's getting like
now's the time i'm going to schedule his
appointment so sad i know i'm sad for
him but i'm also like glad he won't be
like
constantly horny because i just feel
like he can't focus on anything else
because he's always so horny well
he will still be like a little horny but
not nearly as much
yeah i remember when theo got neutered
i'm like oh the problem solved and he's
still like humped a little bit
especially right after the surgery
but it eventually fizzles out now theo
only humps but he's like
really riled the [ __ ] up yeah like when
he sees
you um
for sure and also i just feel like
bruno's productivity levels will be
higher once he's like less he can focus
on you know his passions yeah he can't
focus on anything right now
so that's what's new with that's the
latest with bruce
on the loose bruce on the loose a
bruise we hope everyone enjoyed our
subway the musical episode yesterday oh
my god
we watched it a number of times it was
so [ __ ] stellar
and um i got a bunch of suggestions and
one that i was remiss devastated and
heartbroken not to have included is like
when you take the train in from jersey
welcome to new york um
it's been waiting for you speaking of
taylor swift
speaking of taylor swift let's get into
the fast life stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
because these are stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and honestly i wouldn't be rdh i would
be
pms if i didn't tell everyone that
today's episode is brought to you by
flex
and they are innovating period care with
products that are body safe
made for comfort and made to keep you
moving the flex
disc is a one-time menstrual disc that
fits perfectly inside your body
one flex disc can be worn for up to 12
hours and holds as much flow
as three super tampons it's not a cup
it's unlike any other period product
you've seen before
and it's the only product you can wear
for mess free period sex
flex discs reduce waste
by 60 compared to pads and tampons so
the planet will thank you too
and if you want to go zero waste check
out the flex cup a reusable cup made
with a velvety soft material for a
comfortable fit
if you've thought about trying a
menstrual cup this is the one flex
offers the only menstrual cup on the
market with a pull tab so you remove it
the way you'd remove a tampon
it's so easy you already know how to use
it and your flex cup is 100 reusable and
lasts
4 years plus it's completely body safe
and
non-toxic flex products are worth the
learning curve and flex has videos
diagrams faqs and even live chat flex
births
on their website to help you along the
way whispers
so say goodbye to leaks mess and stress
and say hello to healthier periods for
people and the planet with flex
go to flexfits.comtoast and use the code
toast for 20
off the flex disc starter kits or 10 off
your first flex cup
plus free us shipping that's code toast
at
flex f-l-e-x fits f-i-t-s
dot com slash toast that's code toast at
flex fits dot com
toast love it okay first story taylor
swift announced his imminent drop of
love story re-recording
and an upcoming fearless album just in
time for valentine's day taylor swift is
giving her fans the love story they've
all been waiting for
on thursday morning the superstar
delighted her swifties by announcing
that
the re-recording of her career-changing
song love story would drop at midnight
and if that weren't enough swift also
revealed she's been hard at work
re-recording fearless
which will feature the new name of
fearless taylor's version
the new album will also feature 26 songs
with a total of six
new songs from the vault that she wrote
between the ages of 16 and 18
that she intended to be on the fearless
album but for one reason or another did
not make the cut you know
industry rules but now we're breaking
down industry
walls and she can put as many songs as
she wants on the album
okay so this is like so exciting for so
many reasons obviously like
i knew the love story renewed version
was coming out because it was on the
match.com commercial we've known about
it for a while
and whatever like yeah i was excited
about it but like not gonna you know
[ __ ] my pants over it really i'm not
well who knows but
but i will ship my pants over 26
re-recorded
and six new songs from fearless which is
one of my favorite albums like forever
and always you belong with
me fearless um hey steven
like white horse so many iconic songs
and i love that there's six new songs
that are from that time in her life
because for me like
her songwriting has always been really
strong but like to me that was when it
was like so
innocent and delicious and hadn't
blossomed yet
and i can't wait to hear six more songs
from the mind of the 16 year old taylor
swift i completely agree
when i saw that it was fearless that was
going to be the first album she was
re-recording like
i got so excited fearless is such a
pivotal
masterpiece like but an album in my life
that like it's just
one of my favorite albums of all time
like you belong with me is literally the
reason why we are called the steens like
yeah
it is one of my favorite songs of all
time so that she's re-recording those
songs so we get to listen to them all
over again
is so exciting but that we are also
getting six songs that are of the same
elk which are my favorite crazy
i did not think i would be this excited
about the re-releasing right because i
don't know what i expected but i kind of
thought
crazy tips start yeah maybe start with
greatest hits or maybe start with like
red or something
i just i haven't thought that much just
the fact that
taylor swift that's what i assumed she
was gonna do and while i love and
respect
the debut album it is not one of my tops
yeah and i would have listened to the
re-recorded album and like stand until
the day i die but fearless you're right
is like a special piece of music
in the grand scheme of the world of
music but also like in our personal
lives
it's such a transformative album like i
just i have so many associations like
being a camping in high school listening
to these songs
and they really like shaped us as people
so i'm so thrilled she decided to go
with fearless it's also the first time
she won grammy for album of the year and
i think
really catapulted her to another like
pop star level of fandom
and no pop star level of fame and
it's just so exciting i'm like pissed
that we have to wait until april [ __ ]
9.
so that was the easter egg she
capitalized a few letters very lemony
snicket of her if you guys have read the
series of unfortunate events it's clear
that taylor has two because that is such
a violet beauregard move
she capitalized all the letters that
sent us violet beauregard is from
chocolate factory violet right
violet beauregard is charlie and the
chocolate batteries are crossing are you
sh
yeah but no that sounds right but i let
you turning violet lemony
snicket violet violet yeah that works
probably just a different last name
baudelaire
very very similar that's confusing that
is confusing yeah
i don't blame you it's a violet
baudelaire move wow i didn't even
realize how similar those names were
also um what the [ __ ] is lemony snicket
series of unfortunate events the books
you know it sounds familiar never read
out
okay but then it's fine say you didn't
read it even though the books were
fantastic
the show on netflix with jim carrey
as count olaf i don't know what you're
talking about oh my gosh
i mean i never really watched the show
because i had kind of outgrown it by
then but the books were so good not that
you would ever read them now like you're
ever going to read them as when we were
kids
you guys the lemony snicket chef's kiss
i was more of a harriet the spy kind of
girl
yeah but these were like it was a series
of unfortunate events it was these
three off orphans the baudelaires their
parents passed away they have to go live
with their
mean cousin but they have a big fortune
and count olaf who is played by jim
carrey in the movies he keeps popping up
in all these different live
like ways of their in their life like
but in disguises but they always know
it's him because he has an eye tattoo on
his ankle and every time they see it
they're like spooky
but the baudelaire children are geniuses
and they find a way out of everything
violet sends messages a lot taylor swift
got it okay right that's what we were
talking about thank you for bringing it
back home and
she let us know that it's probably
dropping april 9th
very exciting i'm so happy for taylor
the album covers sickening it's an
homage to
her curly haired fearless cover hair in
the wind but it's more mature
her hair isn't as curly anymore but it's
still like it's very similar but it's
like
it's like the new taylor swift vibe
inspired by the old taylor swift yeah
it's like a collab
between the two tailors yeah it's like
16 year old taylor met 30 year old
taylor and they made this cover together
yeah but it also just looks like a
picture taken on an iphone with the
sepia filter on it which
i respect as well it's just a great day
to be a taylor swift fan
we got so much more than we were
expecting like i was really expecting
just
love story and like that's like a decent
announcement but it's not i wasn't
expecting just that because that's not
like gma worthy
yeah but this also kind of looks like
the lover cover
yeah well her hair is just the same no
when her face is
she's just been giving us so much like
this will now be her third
album in a year because folklore was
released
like that's just crazy that is crazy and
we're just used to getting so little
from her and just like appreciating
every crumb and now i'm like genuinely
feeling
overwhelmed but i'm also glad i mean
april 19 is a little far away i wish it
was dropping in like
two or three weeks because i'm glad that
we have this lead up to get excited
but it's a little too much time i agree
just a little too much but that's what
it used to be like we like before
bc before covid we used to find out
about albums like a year in advance and
like we would have to wait so long so
like
in the group especially in the taylor
world this goes back to like old taylor
so in the grand scheme of things like
okay what it's february may is
april is it's two months like right
march april
yeah two months it's like not that crazy
but in covet times it's an eternity
it's an eternity but maybe we could
spend that time listening to the old
versions because then i'm never
listening to them ever again
like once the new ones come but i see
like i
us true swifties like haven't really
streamed that music
yeah but actually i own the fearless
album on itunes it's actually on all the
albums
on itunes so i guess if i play them on
my they already made money
right silver that's fine okay and i
bought it when taylor was still a part
of it i think taylor would understand
okay so just don't stream it
i'll send you guys illegally if anybody
wants it no she won't
no that's a joke president biden
and madam vice president
i was kidding piracy is a very serious
issue
and fbi it's 250 000 finalists to
remember that
thing they put up before the movie so
i'm 100
kidding she's a comedian i am comic
and i was hitting great love to see it
thank you so much for your service
bless america um so very exciting news
for the swifties you know
it's been a great year for swifties
v-e-n-f-t-s
yes benfice next up morgan wallen breaks
his silence after using a racial slur
tells fans not
to defend him quote i was wrong morgan
wallin is taking ownership of his
actions after he was captured on video
what um website is this
this is people magazine after he was
captured on video using the n-word on
wednesday the country music star
released a five-minute instagram video
addressing his use of the racial slur
urging fans not to defend him as he
wants to quote take ownership
for the offense he said i'm long overdue
to make a statement regarding my last
incident i wanted to collect my thoughts
seek some real guidance and come to you
with a complete thought before i did
according to wall in the video that
surface was taking dir was taken during
a bender
which he said was something was not
something i'm proud of either
72 hour bender he said it was the 72nd
hour of a 72 hour bender
so i want to dive into this because i
was really waiting to hear from him
and i think that the apology was
decent in some ways and atrocious in
some other ways
one we'll start with the negatives
because i'm a negative person
um it was so clearly scripted and
i think that very little attempt was
made to make it seem like it wasn't
scripted like it's been a week like
and whether or not he wrote it or
someone else like whenever you sound
scripted people doubt you
so even if these were his words and he
just wanted to read it from a paper so
he didn't forget anything like that i
understand
but it just sounded very scripted he had
like he couldn't even take a breath
between the sentences like it was just
that was disappointing well if it's
going to be scripted would you rather
someone pretend like it's not and
sort of lie or just have it be scripted
so you know that they were reading what
they wanted to say i would much prefer
someone say like i wrote down my
thoughts
okay that's what hannah brown did when
she went on instagram live she said i
wrote down my thoughts and i don't want
to forget them and i think that's very
honest and i'm like i can respect that
but to make it seem like
you're thinking of it on off the cuff
like that's just annoying and it was so
clearly
scripted and i'm not saying that means
he didn't write it yeah i thought the
apology
you know just in its words we're
actually pretty good because the
he said a few key things that i think
were really important like one to his
supporters like please stop defending me
because what i did was indefensible
and i think that's like a really um
important thing to say the other thing
was like um
talking about how his first apology was
trash
yeah and how he he said that he had
written more and some of the
publications like only chose a few lines
but regardless like it wasn't nearly
appropriate enough
um and the third thing that he said that
i thought was important was
um the sobriety of it all so he says
he's nine days sober now
yeah which um obviously is not an excuse
and i do think he has a very long
journey of
healing and self-discovery in front of
him and this is a step like i always
want to assume that people
are capable of changing because i know
that they are but again this is not my
apology to either accept or not accept
and i will leave it at that i think it
was fine it wasn't
it wasn't great i thought like i agree
with you i think that his words
he said a lot of things that really
struck
a chord and i think also this is a theme
that we were seeing even
randomly in real housewives of salt lake
city it's like you can apologize for
something but forgiveness is given when
the actions change afterwards
so i think that him sitting down and i
believe that he wrote what he wanted to
say and then
read it because you don't want to get it
wrong and you don't want to forget
something but i think this is a really
good first step for him and as he said
he's going on a journey like he's gonna
go off the grid for a little bit and
who knows if he's gonna get like fully
sober he's also said that he would be
meeting
with groups to educate himself the naacp
recently offered to meet with him
and he said that he accepted some
invitations from some amazing black
organizations
and you know what i thought that was a
great thing that he said too was like he
was really
like the you know everything was
happening all around him and
leaders from black organizations and
black communities were reaching out to
him to educate him and kind of like you
know
help him and he's like even when i like
so grossly offended them like they could
have stepped on my neck and like you
know
they reached out to me which was like he
says meant a lot to him so
overall i agree like the words of the
apology were actually
pretty good i think the delivery was
kind of weak and i'm just looking at it
from like a strategic standpoint because
like i have made an apology video myself
like
i'm i just think it was um the delivery
was met but again it's like not
my apology to accept it's not our
apologies to accept
so i'm just i'm curious to see like what
he does with his life
yeah and what the next steps are as yeah
being a first step
i just think like as like like like i
said like i'm not black it's not on me
to accept his apology but as a fan i'm
just like tired of like
his like drama you know yeah but i think
he's
like behave it seems like he's tired of
it too and i think that he wants to make
real change in his life on a number of
levels
and he's going to go and do that yeah
well i'm always going to champion
someone who wants to better themselves
right and i'm not going to you know kick
them while they're down
so hopefully hopefully we'll see a new
morgan
mm-hmm nmw new morgan woman okay ready
for our next story
yeah the bachelor's chris harrison is
apologizing for quote
speaking in a manner that perpetuates
racism this
was [ __ ] weird yeah earlier this week
the longtime host
addressed the controversy surrounding
current contestant rachel kirk connell
while speaking with bachelor nation's
rachel lindsay
although harrison told lindsay he wanted
fans to quote have a little grace with
kirk connell in the wake of her
resurfaced and racially insensitive
photos
his comments didn't sit well with some
fans even resulting in a petition
calling for
him to be removed from the franchise now
he in a statement harrison admitted to
quote wrongly speaking in a managed
manner that perpetuates racism and he
apologized to fans
he said to my bachelor nature bachelor
nation family i will always own a
mistake when i make one
so i am here to extend a sincere apology
i have this incredible platform to speak
about love and yesterday i took a stance
on topics which i should have
have been better informed while i do not
speak for rachel kirk connell my
intentions were simply to ask for grace
in offering her an opportunity to speak
on her own behalf
yeah this was really bizarre and after
the i watched the interview i was left
feeling you know 100 convinced that
rachel connell is the winner of the
season
because i've never seen somebody like so
blindly defend someone
yeah like chris harrison did rachel
connell especially chris harrison he
never doesn't get involved in anything
so i'm convinced that she's the winner
yeah which is a bummer that it's sort of
spoiled
and it's weird because all this stuff
has come out about her
and she's dating possibly engaged to a
black man and i think that rachel
lindsay steered the conversation with
chris harrison very well and i know
rachel lindsay is very
passionate about things like this and i
think that chris harrison among his many
mistakes in that conversation was just
being so like flippant about the whole
thing
and like really kind of talking down to
rachel when
of the two of them rachel is the expert
on racism like not you
chris harrison so i i felt like he just
came into the conversation like so
weirdly strong and he was just like
dying on this hill where he was kind of
wrong pretty much wrong
and i just found it so bizarre and i'm
like thinking to myself why is
i thought it was weird that he was
defending a contestant so hard which is
not something he ever does
and b especially when you know her
what she's being held accountable for
like she needs to be held accountable
for
and i think rachel's point which was
really well said is like
okay but like when are we gonna hear
from her yeah and i think now after all
of this too like it is time to hear from
her i've always been under the
impression yes that can contestants
can't speak on anything they can't go on
podcasts they can't do anything
until after they're eliminated from the
show but rachel lindsay said
that she is under like no contractual
obligation
to not speak about this yeah so now that
it's become
an even bigger conversation and i feel
like it started out um like on the
internet and
read it and you have to be really into
like bachelor news to have heard about
it but now it's very much in the stream
stream
chris harrison is like speaking about it
apologizing about it
i think it's time to hear from rachel i
agree and that's pretty much like the
point rachel was trying to make aside
from like chris harrison making
going on so many bizarre tangents like
about like confederate statues like i
literally didn't know what he was
talking about he was going
and he was just being so weird um
rachel's whole point was like
of course like we let's give people a
chance to explain themselves
explain yourself rachel like she's just
been m.i.a
yeah so i think rachel handled the whole
conversation really well especially
given the fact that like
chris harrison was like kind of
condescending the whole time and he was
like i don't know rachel
do we need to talk about racism like
[ __ ] like it's like chris harrison has
not been
alive this last you know one or two
years where like the con
we're changing how we talk about race
and racism in america it was like i felt
like i was watching an interview like
from 2008. like it was so bizarre
yeah and i just was left 100 convinced
every choker connell is the winner so
i think we can pretty much call it yeah
we wouldn't defend anyone and protect
them so hard if they weren't a winner
yeah i have a feeling we'll be hearing
for from her soon but i guess the
initial plan was to wait until
after the show because that's what's
been done in the past
when a winner had controversy or someone
who was a runner-up like we
heard from them when the season ended
but i just feel like with social media
everything
the pace of everything is just faster
and
i think we should be hearing from her
soon i agree
and just kudos to rachel lindsay for
staring that conversation because it was
it was painful at times and it was long
too it was 14 minutes yeah it was long
longer than normal extra tv segments it
has the same thought
multiple ads served to me in the youtube
video yeah and i was like
is this whole conversation about rachel
corconell and all 14 minutes were about
it
yeah so bizarre
and i do think that probably because
rachel lindsey
is uh still doing the bachelor rhett
podcast happy hour she's still under a
some form of bachelor
contract with abc so i'm sure she
couldn't you know really say what she
wanted to say to chris harrison
yeah agreed okay next story is really
exciting for
toasters and people everywhere rebecca
black drops up friday
toasters and human beings everywhere yes
i guess they are one in the same
yes rebecca black drops a friday remix
with a wild new music video
um this was just something that like
nobody asked for but that we all needed
and we did not even know desperately
internet sensation rebecca black is
celebrating the 11th anniversary of her
song friday
in psychedelic psychedelics
and it's like should have been for the
10th uh yeah or like wait four more
years the 15th
yeah but it couldn't have come in a
better time because we're just like we
literally sing the song like multiple
times a week yeah i don't know if i'll
be singing this new techno version no
it's super techno
it's not my vibe no but i'm just like
glad for the renewed excitement for the
song yeah no of course and
i love that she's leaning into it yes
and she is like a bonafide influencer
these days
and so i love when you know people go
back to
maybe their roots embarrassing thing
that makes them famous no because she's
kind of evolved past it especially on
tick tock she's like a queer tic toc
icon like she's really big on tick tock
she has like a successful influencing
um career so she doesn't have to like go
back to the same which she actually has
talked about like
although it was like funny and fun for
us like she actually like had to do a
lot of therapy because of it you would
imagine it's
traumatizing yeah so it's this thing
that like we look back on it fondly i
don't think that she does
well maybe now she does maybe she's
gotten to a place now but like she was
13 years old when this video came out
and it was like
part of like it was like you know an
after school activity to like go write a
song and make a music video and it went
completely viral and like not in
the most positive way i can imagine that
is extremely traumatizing right so i
think it's very cool and i'm sure was
probably like part of her therapy to
redo this this must be
liberating but the song sucks
like the new version it's like don't
would you repaint the mona lisa
like why would you do that no you you
wouldn't like you don't [ __ ] with the
masterpiece but
i'm sure they just had fun with it big
frida's on the song and i think rebecca
black was really excited to get um
other people involved like she was
excited to see that people that want to
be involved it's just not my particular
genre of music so
i also think she should have gotten you
involved but that's just me no i think
she should have
used this set hundred percent
yeah so check it out if you're looking
for something i watched the video it was
cute
it was cute if you're looking for some
great new jams yeah it's also on our
instagram
yeah if you are epileptic i would not
recommend watching the video it was very
strobing
it actually had a strobe warning on the
opening card the title card well that's
nice at least yeah fifth and final story
some add drama some a d
a d add drama add drama the n
council is quake oh my god or like the
parents tv association like they're
quaking what's the news it's actually
some drama bruce springsteen super bowl
ad oh my god
has been scrapped from jeep's youtube
page amid a dwi bust
for oh [ __ ] yep bruce springsteen super
bowl lv jeep commercial which we talked
about and a lot of people did um was
yang from youtube on wednesday after the
legends dwi bus came to light
the claim is it a new it just happened
november 14th he got a dwi and like the
um
how did the media like not find out i
don't know it was at a national park
it's
like so oh my god yeah a national park
yeah if you do something bad in a
national park like you could literally
be like
sentenced to life in prison like crazy
[ __ ] happens on national parks
yeah because they're national it's just
better parks
yay maybe that still sounds like what it
might be no but it's definitely federal
property the clip
is now unavailable it says this video is
private the hollywood reporter first
reported that the ad had been taken off
of g
jeep's page at around 1 pm the
commercial wasn't on jeep's twitter on
wednesday
um it was revealed that bruce was
arrested at november bruce
i was just thinking that like to me he's
not bruce he's bruce springsteen but
then when you realize that he has the
same name as your dog
i know and i feel like people might
think when i call him bruce on instagram
that i named him after
bruce springsteen or bruce offer oh
i mean all of the above yeah um okay
here's
it it was revealed that bruce
springsteen not
fit chapman juan rep sprezzo sweets
was arrested november 14th at a national
park in his home state of new jersey and
charged with the dwi
reckless driving and consuming alcohol
in a closed area
a spokesperson for the national park
service said springsteen was cooperative
cooperative throughout the process
according to tmz which first reported
the arrest the allegedly juiced
bruce has a cruise on the juice
bruce on the juice has a court date
coming in the next
few weeks and has no known prior busts
for dwi
a jeep spokesperson said it would be
inappropriate to comment on the matter
that the brand can't substantiate
but they said quote it's also right that
we pause our big game commercial until
the actual facts can be established
its message of community and unity is as
relevant as ever
as is the message that drinking and
driving can never be condoned but
community and unity
you're a car brand and your spokesperson
just got arrested
for drunk driving like that is quite
possibly the worst thing
bruce springsteen could have done during
his time
as the chief spokesperson he would have
been better off killing someone
because it's not maybe if it was a hit
and run that would be bad
but like you know what i mean like the
direct association between the jeep
of course and the drunk driving is so
bad of course so good on them for taking
it down
i didn't even know like i think it's so
crazy that this kind of went under the
radar in the world can get a dwi
and we don't hear about it right no
that's
that's power yeah that's true power and
you i feel like
bruce can you imagine like being the cop
who had to arrest bruce springsteen he's
probably like bruce i'm sorry i love
your work you know yeah it would have
been good if it was me because i
didn't recognize him yeah yeah yeah or
like don't know any of his songs i know
like two yeah
baby i was born to run
i don't think that's how it goes i think
as we were born i just made it selfish
and i
know that one zack shapiro loves
rosalita
and then i think that's it yeah i'm sure
there's more oh yeah that one where he's
like
bruce on the loose bruce on the loose
seriously not cool to drink and drive
don't [ __ ] do it whether you're bruce
springsteen or just a fabulous toaster
there's nothing fabulous
about drinking and driving 100 and
honestly
i'm judging bruce springsteen you know i
actually really really like
i'm i'd like to act dead serious like i
really like to pride myself on being
someone who's not judgmental like
at all like you can tell me things about
your lifestyle and i really feel like
i'm so
open i do not judge people and i always
think like if i were ever a housewife
that would probably be like my greatest
feature like i really think that
but i judge people so you do you take it
really seriously i have not [ __ ] with
sam hunt
since he did that and like barely gave
us an apology like i don't support like
and i'm not into cancel culture just
personally like
i think it's so disgusting like drink
and drive to drink and drive and like i
i think of you so differently but other
than that like i'm really not judgmental
okay i'm really not okay so what you're
saying is you're judging bruce
i'm hardcore judging bruce like you're
the richest person in the world like
get a driver and like drivers are so
elegant and cheek and then you could
like
drink in the back like it's ideal drink
in the back like a rock star
yeah like get a limousine it's just it's
so stupid
yeah same with sam hunt like all the
resources in the world
take an uber black well no in the age of
uber there's
no excuse no excuse for nothing and
there ever was but still you're right
uber
lift anywhere you go i went on tour 260
cities
every single one of them had lift or
some sort of ride share there's no
excuse a hundred percent
okay you know like
you know like what would happen to me no
do you know what i'm gonna say i don't
know but i don't want you to even say no
like
let's say like 10 years from now like
i'm going through something dark and
like i get arrested for twi like this a
clip goes viral
100 but no i wouldn't i would never
mostly because like i can barely drive
sober like
let alone drunk yeah that's why i just
don't drive at all yeah no for sure
um don't [ __ ] do it temper tv recap
yes wheelhouse says the salt lake city
part one reunion recap is brought to you
by ancestry
there are many paths to finding your
family story whichever way you choose
tracing your family generations back
with a family tree
or uncovering your ethnicity with an
ancestry dna it's easy to get started
with ancestry
an anti an ancestry dna test tells you
where your ancestors are from
and ancestries billions of records and
millions of family trees let you
discover their personal stories
you could find a famous relative rather
be sick or perhaps a photo of your great
grandma as a little girl
whatever you find it's sure to change
the whole way you look at your family
history
and yourself after all the story of your
family is the story of you
research researching your history is a
fun activity for the whole family and
the stories you learn about your shared
past
can bring you closer together ancestry
dna can reveal ethnic origins
and provide historical details that
bring unique families stories to life
ancestry dna doesn't tell you which
countries you're from but it can also
pinpoint the specific regions within
those countries giving you insightful
geographic details about your history
trace the paths of your recent ancestors
and learn how and why your family
moved from place to place around the
world no other dna test delivers such a
unique
interactive experience it's easy to
start making discoveries with ancestry
get grab an ancestry dna kit and start a
free trial to amplify your discoveries
with ancestry's billions of records
start exploring your family's story
today head to our link ancestry.com
toast to get your ancestry dna kit and
start your free trial
that's ancestry.com toast
love it okay part one of the real house
is the salty city reunion it was
very exciting like something about
seeing all the women like together being
civil like was kind of weird because i
don't think
since the lunch mary's red carpet
met gala have we had every single woman
together yeah because mary did not
participate in anything but then she
showed up and showed out for their
eating
she was very lucid and i think that's
probably been one of her
biggest people i've critiqued her the
most for like she's kind of all over the
place
in her storytelling and in her
conversations but i thought she was
very clear-headed i thought she was
great i loved seeing her but it did feel
weird it's like
seeing a dog walk on his hind legs i'm
like i'm not used to seeing mary
sit down and talk to every single person
yeah i agree but
she did she did a great job for herself
and i actually feel like she could be a
housewife again
next season yeah um but they'll just
have to do it like they need to solve
this thing between jen and mary because
i think they'll both be back next season
and they need to be able to film
together yeah but you know what i felt
like and i know it was only part one but
i wasn't even that interested in the
mary verse gen
i'm really shook at like lisa and jen
versus the world this lisa and jen
alliance is so bizarre
because i really cannot pinpoint any
moment this season of them
but yeah no they clearly are very much
having each other's backs i feel like
lisa
sees that she's not going to be well
america's sweetheart and that like
being friends with heather like heather
is really this the breakout star
of the season like so beloved rihanna's
damning her that was crazy
that was crazy and so i think lisa sees
that she probably
erred in that but that also jen shot is
a huge
star from this season so she's gonna
attach herself yes
yeah lisa's so like shallow and i can
really like see through all of her
decision making
and how she just loves being a housewife
and wants to be well liked
and i think the comment that she made
towards the end of the episode blaming
heather for the audience not liking her
she's like the audience doesn't like me
and sends me dms calling me
and name calling is not correct but to
blame heather
who you're arguing with on a show for
people not liking you is so backwards
like maybe people don't like you because
everyone in the room is saying the exact
same thing like you act like you're
better like than everyone
and so if everyone came to this
conclusion on their own like maybe it is
time
and i'm a person who's actually very
similar to lisa like i know sometimes
people
think i can be [ __ ] and like i'm very
direct and loud and and i get that and
it definitely does get misconstrued
sometime
sometimes but if every single person i'm
friends with has the same kind of
feeling
after interacting with me that i give
off the vibe that i think i'm better
than them
and that like i talk down to them like
that's a terrible thing way to make
someone feel yeah
and i wish you would just like take that
in more yeah and just reflect on that
and i don't even know any of these women
but when i look at the show what did i
say here three weeks ago i'm like lisa
thinks she's too good for all these
women
yeah so it's like her friends are coming
to that assumption the audience like
maybe it's time to just reflect inward
and be like why do i give off that vibe
yeah like you don't have to be so
defensive all the time
it was just frustrating and that that
whole thing of her blaming heather was
insane
and backwards like that's not how it
works yeah and to me i feel like the
clearest
example of her thinking she was better
than the other women was when she had
that
dinner on the mountain for like business
women in salt lake city
her fellow business women on the show
and it's like oh no you're not the kind
of business woman
yeah and what i thought was most
interesting was learning more about jen
shaw's business because because it seems
like because we've been saying like an
assistant
college football coach doesn't live this
lifestyle bomb on chanel versace
everything romantician shall i
party party party it seems like she's
the breadwinner in the family which i
thought was so interesting
and her company sounds like a like a
legit tech business like
yeah it sounded really interesting i
would love to know more i i agree
maybe we'll get more next season like
maybe they'll say oh the viewers were
interested in this like let's focus on
this as your personal storyline
because i totally agree that was the
vibe that i got to and
i'm very much here for it and interested
in learning more right and it's like a
super successful company like she's not
every day you know in meetings about it
but it's like it's a self-sufficient
company i thought that was
fascinating heather is so clearly like
the queen of the show and i think her
and whitney
whitney in the beginning i felt was a
little weak but i think like
she's not a confrontational person but
the show kind of makes you into that
type of person
and i think together they're an
unstoppable duo and i love that meredith
is like sitting on their side
even though like i don't think she's
really on their side um but i just need
her because like the three of them are
my queens it also
feels like there's some tension between
meredith and lisa yes i do think we will
unpack it in part two and three which is
crazy and also a little sad they've been
friends for 10 years and then like the
show is one season
but wow i guess it also like when the
cameras go up like you see people for
who they really are i don't know what
happens between them
but that would make me a little bit sad
but yeah better to know than to not know
i did have one problem with where
meredith was sitting due to her side
part
i did feel like half the time i could
only see her left eye and i wish she
either moved the part to the other side
so we could see like
like face hair as opposed to face
hair when the camera's over there do you
know what i'm saying yeah it was like
very emo
like mom i'm working on my art right now
yeah that's that's true i also didn't
think that meredith deserves
third i thought the seating was bizarre
yeah
because it's okay so it's andy in the
middle and then flanking is heather and
jen
perfect yeah then it was lisa
or mary next lisa and then mary yeah i
should have been in the third seat
i shouldn't marry but i guess they
wouldn't no actually it should have been
it should have been heather whitney mary
yes heather whitney mary jen
meredith lisa but you know what i think
the three of them have a lot of conflict
and it would have been yeah
looking i also think now that ever for
the last couple reunions everyone's had
to be six feet apart like it does
change the typical template of
housewives seating charts yeah it's not
the same
yeah i feel like auntie was having like
the best time because it's like fresh
women
he's been he's used to doing reunions
with people who've been on the show for
10 years like
these women are fresh and they're
feeling they're not calculated at all
like they're just saying what they feel
because
this is also new to them and i think
andy was like having the time of his
life yeah and i think that the show has
been really well received and i think
it's an exciting
thing for him and i i i can imagine even
though it's so fabulous to us i'm
sure it gets mundane for him and we even
sent it sometimes in like
oc reunion 12 hours days like just
shooting
so i think that it was like a
re-invigoration
excitement and you know the biggest
topic of conversation that came out of
the reunion was lisa barlow's spray tan
her hands were like so dark and patchy
and honestly that's really unacceptable
like as a housewife like
yeah glam like has to be perfect perfect
and she's usually on point very i
actually love her dress
me too the when i saw the individual
photos of what everyone was wearing i
was like
what questions they're actually quite a
fashionable bunch
um but they they looked okay on the show
just like i don't know
some was some of it was weird heather's
was bad heathers was bad with
gen chaz is terrible whitney's dress was
huge
yeah it was but actually meredith looked
fire at least it looked great mary
not my personal style but i still
respect it and i like that she has her
own personal style and she didn't give
in like when they were like what is with
your green luffa dress like she was like
it's versace i like it not everyone can
pull it off you don't like it you don't
wear it like that's actually a
really respectable response i appreciate
that i hate when people like
you know clown on someone no oh i hate
that but i also hate when someone is
there themselves
and it's not well received so they
change who they are so they change what
they look like and it's like
no just have the courage to be who you
are
you know i definitely think i i'm the
former but still no i'm sure i i mean i
think that
you regard that but i actually felt the
opposite i felt the same way about lisa
too it was like
she saw how she came off on the show and
considering she really wants to be on
the show and be well like she could have
like
at the reunion but instead she kind of
doubled down on who she is
and even though um i have like some
issues with her i kind of respected that
she stood up for herself that's a really
fair point
but i did really start
to warm up to her when she started
crying about her kids not that i want
her to cry
but it's like finally there's a human
being behind this like perfect mormon
woman like
it was just i don't think first of all
i'd ever seen her cry thus far and i
think we've pretty much seen everyone
cry
or like be emotional and that's what
andy was saying too she was just like so
stoic and like wanted to win every
argument
and be like jiffable and like memeable
and like she won the argument
and just to see her break down not that
i want to see her sad but it's like oh
my god there is a
real human being behind this character
and
everyone has been vulnerable like
heather's dad passing away jen's dad
passing away
meredith and her struggles with her
husband
mary opened up about her like it was
really hard for her to marry her [ __ ]
step grandfather 20 years ago like
whitney and all the [ __ ] she's been
through like everyone has been so honest
except for lisa she's like my business
like it was just like so vapid
yeah and it was nice to see her open up
and i hope we see more like genuine
sides of her like more
human sides for like nobody cares that
you're the most successful the most be
like you don't have to be the most
everything just be a human being
yeah i agree with that i also feel like
there's a chance right now i'm like
unsure of lisa and in some moments i'm
like yeah in another moments i'm like
oh no oh no no no no no no
but i feel like she could be one of
those people who it takes like a few
seasons to fully
understand dorit cameron west scott
harley davidson
and like once you're you understand her
like
maybe she's everything of the sort like
i don't know but i
just i only feel that way because every
time i there's a new episode i feel
differently about her and i just feel
like i'm
learning more but i don't i do think
like we need to see more from her if you
have to get to that place that's all i'm
saying and she has to open up more like
she can't
survive on housewives like just being
like business business business like
that's not fun
yeah open up what are you sad about what
makes you happy lisa vanderpump what
keeps you up at night like
these are the things that make a great
housewife vulnerability honesty
transparency you might just take time
with her
not everyone it's just like oh ready
it's time to be open here i am like
agreed
and i think people can relate to that
too i just right now
i think you know she's didn't come off
the best this season but i feel like
there could be
more to her yeah no i just found it
really interesting that like jen chow
was clear like the obvious villain this
season but
for some reason i'm feeling like the
reunions are going in the direction of
like
everyone versus lisa and i just want to
know like why this lisa
gen alliance yeah i feel like we will
get
to know more but i also don't think we
got into the
gen stuff like from vegas and from
sheriff's deputies
we haven't gone there yet so so who
knows what's going on yeah and i did
feel like the footage was really um
doing lisa dirty because she was like so
judgmental to whitney about dancing at
sharif's party
when she full-on did the splits whitney
brought it up and they cut to a clip of
a clip of her like that's
what people mean when they say like you
think you're better than everyone so
like if whitney dancing is trashy
you doing it is fine yeah that's like
hypocrisy the definition of hypocrisy
yes
so uh the editors were just really on
one i also feel like next season like i
don't need
them to add any housewives and i don't
need them to take any away i could go
for this group again
get more them getting more comfortable i
completely agree yeah and it's also been
over a year since they filmed this
season like there's
i think there's a lot there yeah i just
i really love meredith she didn't say
one word this entire her part isn't up
yet like she is beef with jen
um so her part isn't up yet but she was
super quiet and
i just find it interesting like she's
not the typical housewife who i would
like gravitate towards but i just love
her
yeah me too no i think she's she's
playing it well so far it's like i'm not
gonna speak unless
spoken to spoken to which very mature
yeah there's it's a long day
it's a long day but those chairs
actually do look comfortable like of all
the chairs this is
also really cute but like the fake
fireplace in the middle yes but it was
like a little like
too um too much dialed it back a little
bit oh i actually really loved
it it was like a lot of like grandma's
house
i liked it i thought it was like no i
love the furs i love the fake snow but
if you looked in the background there
was like so much going on oh i didn't i
didn't look there was so much going on
it looked like crazy
i thought it was a great opening reunion
me too i'm i'm glad that it's three
parts which means that it's juicy
yeah and that means they respect salt
lake city salt lake city
the executives over at bravo now
speaking of housewives i'm really
excited for our
interview coming up if you're watching
on youtube again it's only available as
a podcast because she joined us from
dallas
jen davis from the rail houses of dallas
is taking us on her journey with her
she's
you can tell she's kind of nervous in
the beginning because it's like kind of
a big thing she went through and
part of the reason why she was hired as
a housewife but had to step back
and i think you'll just really
appreciate her honesty and i encourage
everyone to go into it with an open mind
because
it was very cool it was very cool of her
and with that we will see you tomorrow
tomorrow's episode is podcast only
and don't forget to watch little because
we'll be recapping it our toast movie of
the week yes don't forget little
available to stream on hbo max recap
coming at you in tomorrow's podcast only
episode
see you then bye